giorno della partenza e non mi ha mai
visto nella neve sulla neve si nella
neve stesso morto abbiamo ora a 5 ore di
treno dobbiamo arrivare a trento e poi
da prendere ma già manca preso il
biglietto per tre
spero di non averlo preso e trieste
oddio
come stai bene bene ma è anche la tuta e
tutto certo roba termica pincio botto
file anch'io però è qua dentro tutti ma
là dentro
com'è possibile che sei pronto a chicago
non è detto che poi rischio di morire
addirittura si non nessuna leggerezza di
camogli roba che ha incrociato l'opera
grazie gianmarco sta imparando a montare
questo enrico è oberato di lavoro
ora capisco perché siete pazzi training
dei provinati dominio
tutti i ragazzacci coar turbo fondo
siamo arrivati a trento legati a trento
dei ricordi bellissimi
perché ho fatto trento e peter è un film
hanno mai pagato oppure indicato col
regista per questo film perché mi
dissero che avrebbero pagato questo lo
diceva tre anni fa mai
l'olimpo sarebbe perdi la voce neve c'è
il freddo dove c'è freddo neve fa ti ho
fatto un popolo naturalmente ho visto
riconosciuto guardate che carina quindi
c'è il mio letto e il della vigna abbia
fatto una chiacchiera con luca io mi ero
portato tutte delle cose ha ceduto che
ha fatto questo qui che è quella
dell'associazione 6 piacere è vero
questo caso che capponi gli occhiali
abbinati ma scusa quelli vanno fuori
secondo me ecco perché la fascia
dell'occhiale va a messa sopra il casco
una cosa abbastanza
tranquilla visto
il primo e secondo questa sera e per
domani ancora prima di iniziare a
studiare la pena torniamo in camera
partono le scommesse su quanto andrai
lungo il lato sinistro
devo dire che sono molto tranquillo devo
essere sincero buio credo in testa no
chiamata e barelle lady volte le darà
medici non tanto a prendere il treno per
napoli e rullo di tamburi sono in
perfetto ritardo sono stato parecchio
fortunato perché la meta è passata
subito quindi devi essere molto veloce
con la seggiovia perché se sbagli i
caschi nel dirupo
buon inizio che ti dino tifata ho un po
di ansia costituita dai siamo qui con
luca jurman che il fondatore della pista
e stiamo facendo nessuna minima che
accada per farvi capire di che cosa
stiamo parlando di cosa si occupano
master alla maschera nazionale artisti
tv perché ormai tu sei fregato ragazzi
voi si occupa di creare un futuro per i
bambini con disabilità portare sulla
neve sviluppare il loro talento è
portare poi le paralimpiadi questo
nostro obiettivo quindi trovare
selezionare a fare un po da scouting per
la federazione di cui siamo chiaramente
portavoce siamo patrocinati da loro
periodo facevamo le chiacchiere ci siamo
conosciuti e abbiamo avuto modo di
parlare forse un pochino via fondi detto
una cosa non è bellissima è una cosa che
si può dare di più un bambino oltre
ovviamente a un aiuto è un sorriso la
felicità la cosa che ci interessa è più
felici è vedere che finalmente i
genitori possono capire che i loro figli
possono avere un futuro professionistico
qualche cosa che in questo caso nello
sport trovare un obiettivo per la cosa
più bella è che non si è mai veramente
parlato di disabilità ma sempre parlato
di potenzialità ed è la cosa veramente
più belle in assoluto adesso è arrivato
un nuovo allievo ok e vediamo un pochino
del caso se non prendi il discorso neve
su o'shea con timore oddio chissà se
riuscirò
c'è la discesa ma ti diverti
la tv come un bambino che nessuno torna
bambino è un posto con te devo
ricordarti che se vero punto sei a tuo
agio per niente i miei stivali danno un
aggio sono una cosa meravigliosa
la neve alta e più sei finito comunque
non me lo immagino di questa consistenza
e proprio completamente un profano della
neve e io sulla medici sono stato ma
quella lì è presente quando tipo medica
a roma ha chiesto da puffo puffo pesino
bella quella è la seggiovia eba tromba
la dovrei essere molto preparata
permette di creare non significa tenere
l'evento nei liquidi non si tra l'altra
mattina
lontane sarebbero i palloni senza ok e
soul indietro vicino rispondono che
voglio io sto in avanti dalla centrale
allora non si aspetta sistemi di frenata
alternativi ci sono cose strano su
lunghi c'è guglielmo che sta lavorando
con la maestra di sci lo inquadra eremo
mentre scende da questa discesa moderata
tutto sommato quello abile e il suo
istruttore chiaramente attenzione però
vedo qualcosa di buono ma bravissima
insegnare a che livello sei arrivato
[Musica]
addirittura un livello medio
va beh insomma sa più o meno come sa
eccolo che l'ho preso e capri non me
l'aspettavo invece lì c'è un caprone ei
caprone ti ho visto cadere
[Applauso]
stop a delle riprese action che la super
sì la prossima spostati proprio bravo
professore che volevo cadere per cammino
sotto se si prova ok una palla rialzarsi
qual è l'obiettivo prender parte alla
competizione demone pista e rosso la
rododentro una lista rossa e considera
che il campione poi si va in un giro
della pista nera a suo piacimento
sì gulizzi gera fai prima a parte la in
salita con le racchette con olio di
gomito che apprendere questo rullo
eterno e come intestarla questa piccola
manovra ci è costata sette anni sono
appena arrivato a napoli ed è risaputo
che invierà a napoli e non si fa una
bella pizza margherita ecco il caso
assicura di stare a napoli che abbiamo
ancora il preside perfetto al diavolo
l'ampiezza quasi magna se magna il
nostro istruttore mi ha dato il permesso
di andare da solo ok ora ti chiedo te la
senti di venire col tuo maestro sopra
che è il mio maestro
io no giammarco io non ho mai messo gli
sci non posso venire con te su una blu
che sono il dilettante anche se è
difficile crederlo difficile la
seggiovia questo odio di face book e
perché lo sta facendo perché non sto
facendo è un all in all in a guarda come
quando a tranquillo ovviamente non
potremo riprendere occhi ancora alla
fine chiude lo sapete che appena non ci
vedranno lì ci ammazzano a me mi
ammazzano non ti ammazzano se scendo
integro si lascia una scia di sangue si
sa ma gli atalantini siamo vivi
mi tremano ancora le gambe sono caduto
tre volte una volta un pezzo
di 90 per compagno lotta per colpa di un
altro che era dietro quindi lo fa un
racchiude alcune preso veloci sera
quello è stato un infame un'altra volta
son caduto non so nemmeno perché ho
ancora tutte le ossa di polsi mamma mia
ragazza voto maurizia son nella linea c
simili se devo essere onesto non abbiamo
fatto la pista blu che ho fatto io
il maestro truffa forze andato nella
seggiovia col maestro e abbiamo
imboccato un percorso lui non era così
fosse guido lui ma non era lo stesso ed
uno era andato nel suo articolo forse sì
perchè lo sanno che voglio farla brutti
solo per far morire inconsapevoli guarda
dobbiamo vedere che cosa dicono loro
appena arriviamo di altre novità giù
insulti proprio bravi abbiamo fatto una
cosa un po criminale ha mandati sulla
pista blu è cascato un paio di volte
allora andato bene quindi non so non so
di non sarà più lavoro io l'abbiamo
proprio anche guardate qua guardate dove
siamo
il paesaggio delle dolomiti
non c'è niente avvicinare travolta
tranquillo non è fatti dai colpi ok non
sarà la pizza però diciamo che ci può
stare dai ragazzi qui c'è un panorama
spettacolare quelle ischia
mi pare vero dicono che sia il momento
di stop
questo è rimasto con la squadra
bruciate la linea invece sta facendo uno
slalom di birre da stamattina è
totalmente ubriaca ci sono delle persone
fuori di testa
pronte a lanciarsi in questo dirupo cosa
che da qua a une riflesso dove i tuoi
capelli sono molto bianchi va bene noi
aspetteremo il lancio tre ro e qualcun
altro che parte servizi su comodati così
bella regata siamo visti tra cui con
bianca ci stiamo facendo la seggiovia a
scendere voi non potete capire nel
fumetto di vuoto assurdo che ci a
mettergli un parapendio ci saluta quella
sotto la linea con un'altra ragazza poco
conosciuto letizia e se sentite urlate
sono allora per esemplare
eccoci alla fine ci siamo pronti per il
provino
oggi diciamo che c'è la prova ufficiale
con gli americani per il film che non
dire mattina però un film ha veramente
che conoscete tutti possiamo dire che
c'è un attore famosissimo al è molto
bravo va bè ragazzi noi andiamo facciamo
questa roba e magari ci riaggiorniamo
dopo dai posti questa volta avremo un
vero e valoroso maestro mario evitare di
farci morire
che bello non avere responsabilità
questa volta siamo e abbiamo senza poi
vai allora rispetto a gianmarco sono
caduto una sola volta ma perché non mi
sono fidato dei miei mezzi e aveva
provando cose il nume stavo provando
cose nuove è grande ma siamo andati fino
alla fine sono molto molto orgoglioso le
cose dice che quando paura tenete a fare
l'opposto di quello che dovresti fare e
quindi acquisti velocità i muri ma io
sono morto già miss orgoglioso
8 parisse pare forse i numeri con cui si
dà mandati da soli a sciare e comunque
dovrei dire una cosa anche a questa
ricetta con cui è giunta dopo averti qui
ho iniziato a seguire il maestro che
andava velocisti altra punta lo aveva
sentito aiuto a dio che strisciava e
sono da me mi sono scrittori nota ha
volato e comunque prima giornata sugli
sci di ogni momento
tornando sui piedi e invece stai in
grande forma ragazzi di themis e dario
non è identico a carlo cracco tour
aspetta carlo cracco siani ragazzi che
mi dici ragazzi
adesso stiamo facendo un bel panino con
la porchetta perché ce lo meritiamo
diciamolo dove ci ha portato emanuela
che ringraziamo
noi comunque restiamo super positivi per
questa roba
la cosa andava bene vi faremo sapere
prestati connessi
ma come visto effettistico a quanto non
essere meraviglioso
siamo al 20 pinzolo vedere che man gioco
di persone ma non li hai detto su
instagram è molto bello che ci sarà
anche uno stato di deficienza e domani
c'è la gara ma proviamo a farci cagare
addosso
eccone un altro che arriva a tromba
[Musica]
siccome oggi non c o leone ha sfidato ad
andare sul bob leo è uno dei bambini di
nasi quest'anno hanno richiamato perché
è bravo e quelli per prepararla e dal
gruppone quale ha deciso di sfidarmi
credo che però una crisi di alzare via
[Applauso]
allora ragazzi
com'è andata appena frena ti prego
scusami si comandato guglielmo per
favore ragazzi dicevo frena prina frena
non sentivo ai freni vediamo se sarei
bravo come le offre male
[Risate]
a tutti arriva la medaglia di questa
gara
tu non lo merita quindi non lo siamo
molto carichi e andando in stazione e
mettiamo insieme all'euro
durante questo registazione faremo degli
scherzi questo può spiegare vuole male a
in una profumeria scusa capitolo per
chiedere scusate sapete dove via le mani
dal naso ok teletutto se stavo a sciare
una settimana compiuta
e da quanto è uscita questa settimana la
mattina mi sono alzata alle 7
certamente quella di presentare come
funziona
com'è andato il campo ci sono altri
bambini da solo
wow e cos'è ti piace di più recitare o
suonare suonare suoni della coca cola
invece temo giudica leo il chitarrista
pianista
[Musica]
sto provando a vedere con questa natura
mentre sono tornato a roma alla stazione
termini
napoli ragazzi è una città fantastica in
realtà è la seconda volta che ci vado eh
sì purtroppo appena perso la metro per
ritornare a casa
e stato molto bello non ho preso alla
fine e la margherita quindi credo di
essere quelli che adesso aspettiamo ogni
volta che arrivo furtiva tu sei inquieta
oddio che una bellissima notizia cosa ma
sei pronto psicologicamente e
fisicamente fisicamente po meno si
voglion ticamente secondo me si sparla
andiamo a sanremo cosa con vanity fair e
il prossimo episodio
www ho fatti dobbiamo portare avanti
no io domanda cantavo
sì devo andare a cantare all'ariston
scusa è scoppiato
dai paparazzi in bocca al lupo ragazzi
[Applauso]
per andare a cantare